لا تزال المعارك مستمره في قطاع غزه
وتحديدا في المناطق الشماليه من قطاع غزه
وتحديدا مناطق شمال محافظه شمال غزه
ومناطق مدينه غزه وما يحيط بها بالاضافه
الى القتال العنيف والمتواصل في مناطق
خانيونس في جنوب قطاع غزه اذا ما بدانا
بالمنطقه الشماليه فنحن نتحدث عن قتال
عنيف تخوضه كتاب القسام وفق اعلاناتها وفق
اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي في ثلاثه محاور في
محور الشجاعيه لا يزال القتال مستمرا
وعنيفا في ذلك المحور بعد الاعلان المتكرر
عن سقوط قتلى وجرحى في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي في منطقه الشجاعيه بالاضافه
الى منطقه مخيم جباليا ومنطقه بيت لاهيه
ومنطقه الشيخ رضوان اذا ما دخلنا الى
منطقه اذا ما دخلنا الى منطقه بيت لاهيه
فنحن نتحدث عن اعلان كتاب القسام انها
استهدفت قوه اسرائيليه
في منطقه بيت لاهيه شمال قطاع غزه
وبالاضافه الى
استهداف قوه اسرائيليه في منطقه الشيخ
رضوان حيث تعود الشيخ رضوان الى الواجهه
الاحداث من جديد مع التوغ الاسرائيليه في
المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه من مدينه غزه
والضغط من جهه الفالوجه على مخيم جبال
التسع قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حتى هذه
اللحظه للدخول الى مخيم الجباليه لكنها لم
تستطع حتى الان تحديد او تحقيق اختراق
واضح المع في مخيم جبالي هذا بالاضافه الى
القتال العنيف كما ذكرنا في منطقه
الشجاعيه وهذه منطقه كما ذكرنا تشهد قتالا
عنيفا بين قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المتوغلة
تحديدا ولكن الحدث الابرز اليوم كان
الحديث عن منطقه جحر الديك في المنطقه
الوسطى من قطاع غزه في هذه المنطقه جحر
الديك التي نتحدث عنها هي هذه المنطقه
منطقه محصوره بين وادي غزه بهذا الشكل في
المنطقه من الجهه الجنوبيه بالاضافه الى
خط الهدنه حتى معبر المنطار ومن الجهه
الغربيه مع شارع صلاح الدين ومن الجهه
الشماليه مع شارع كارني نتساريم هكذا هي
جحر الديك بشكل تقريبي العمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التوغل الاسرائيلي بدا من
بدايه هذه الحرب تقريبا في جحر الديك في
عمق بعض بضع مئات من الامتار لاننا كما
نشاهد على الخريطه نحن نتحدث عن مناطق
زراعيه وبالتالي مناطق فارغه من السكان
وهي بالمناسبه حوالي 6.5 ك م مربع منطقه
جحر الديك ولكن عدد سكانها لا يتجاوز 5000
ساكن فلسطيني لان اذا ما لاحظنا الخريطه
عن قرب نحن نحن نشاهد اننا نتحدث عن مناطق
زراعيه وهي تعرف بسله غذاء قطاع غزه منطقه
جحر الديك لانها منطقه زراعيه وسهل
بالتالي التوغل الاسرائيلي فيها كان في
بدايه هذه الحرب كان توغلا سهلا وتقدمت
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه من جحر
الديك باتجاه مناطق المنطقه الغربيه
ومناطق من شارع صلاح الدين وتجاوزت تلك
المناطق وصولا الى شارع الرشيد في المنطقه
الغربيه من قطاع غزه ولكن اليوم بعد هذا
التوغل الطويل اذا ما اذا ما افترضنا ان
التوغل الاسرائيلي بدا خلال اسبوعين او
ثلاث اسابيع الاولى من هذه الحرب هذا يعني
اننا نتحدث الان عن اكثر من حوالي شهرين
من التوغل الاسرائيلي في منطقه جحر الديك
ولكن كتاب القسام تعود هذا اليوم لتخرج
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه المتمركزه
في جحر الديك وتضرب هذه الاليات العسكريه
والقوات الاسرائيليه الجنود الاسرائيليين
تضربهم من الخلف بطريقه كانت طريقه
دراماتيكيه للغايه في مقطع الفيديو الي
نشرته كتائب القسام اليوم بقي ان نذهب الى
المنطقه الجنوبيه من قطاع غزه ومنطقه
خانيونس التي تشهد عمليات عسكريه مكثفه
وتحديدا وفق اعلان كتائب القسام العمليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه والمقاومه في
المنطقه الشرقيه والمنطقه الشماليه
الشرقيه تقول كتاب القسام بانها تخوض
اشتباكات من المسافه صفر في هذه المناطق
وانها تحقق اصابات مباشره وواضحه في
القوات الاسرائيليه سواء الاليات او
القوات الاسرائيليه الراجله وتحديدا في
المنطقه الشرقيه من خان يونس بين سهيلا و
عبسان الجديده بطبيعه الحال او المنطقه
الشماليه الشرقيه من خان يونس نتحدث عن
الزنه وصولا الى القرار اذا خان يونس في
المنطقه الجنوبيه ونتحدث عن جباليه
الشجاعيه جحر الديك في المناطق الشماليه
من قطاع غزه جحر الديك في المنطقه الوسطى
بطبيعه الحال ولكنها في المناطق الشماليه
او ما بات يعرف بشمالي الوادي في هذه
الحرب المستمره على قطاع غزه منذ اكثر من
70 يوما